a political comedy is just as easy now
as it was during the Bush years the it's
still it's a different cast of
characters but you know they've got all
the same foibles personally you know
speaking for myself I certainly like and
and trust our president now more than I
did our previous one but he makes plenty
of goofs I certainly don't approve of
everything he does and there's a cast of
characters in Washington right now that
are you know absolutely as hilarious as
anyone who's there during the Bush years
we're always looking to keep it fresh
and and and that's not so much because
we need we're scared we're gonna lose
the audience it's more we don't want to
lose our own interest you know you do
the show four days a week you know
however many weeks a year you can get
bored by doing it so we have to keep
making it exciting for ourselves so
there's absolutely there's there there's
that it's like let's try something new
even though it might be hard and there's
also you know weird it's a group of very
competitive funny people and we'd like
to make each other laugh so you know we
where we know what a standard show could
be and we're always trying to break out
of that just so we can impress each
other
absolutely not no III the hardest part
for me in a work environment is
collaboration it's that just a struggle
I've always had and I love my co-workers
and I love you know bouncing ideas
around with them but I've really enjoyed
pure riding just sitting and writing by
myself
you know and every show is different
this is this is the most collaborative
environment I've ever been in I used to
write at a TV show called news radio
where it was very different we didn't
have a any sort of big table or anything
where ideas were bounced around we
really you'd come up with a script ID I
need to go off and ride it you need to
hand it to the next guy up the food
chain and he would rewrite it it was you
know it was as pure a writing experience
as you can get an intro to the TV world
the main difference between the two is
just the immediacy the daily show the
news hits and and we get we get to take
care of it that night The Simpsons
such a strange animal and a wonderful
animal but a strange one you would be
writing for something that wouldn't air
for nine months to a year and and and
and still people would go wow how did
you get that reference you know so
quickly and you know frequently it would
seem like the show was precent I enjoyed
the Simpsons but I tell you what I like
the immediacy of the daily show more it
was frustrating to write something and
then not see the finished product for a
year with The Daily Show it's like
you're really putting on a show
you know I'm Mickey Rooney you know I'm
writing a script and that night it goes
live and if it's terrible well we'll do
another show tomorrow night
oh absolutely we're not so different
from everybody else it's not gone
particularly funny in this interview
anyway so you know we don't always have
to be funny how's that you um yeah well
I think we can be just as adequate at
managing people as others and you know
and look it's it's all management skills
that go into our wheelhouse it's okay I
read a script
this isn't funny this is what you need
to do boop boop boop it's if I were an
accountant I'd be able to point out
where the numbers didn't add up
you know if I'm watching a montage and
this doesn't go together quite right you
know I did someone who is a professional
is a comedy professional I I I can point
out what's going to work better
no I tell you what everyone at the show
is so nice and in so shockingly
competent that it's it's not a real
problem I've been in situations where
there been people who were difficult or
people who just didn't want to be around
people you had to manage more heavily
there's nothing like that there it's and
I think a lot of that has to do with
with the fact that it's such a
fast-moving machine anyone who who acts
as any sort of sand in the gears gets
spit out pretty quickly